[Music]
welcome back to hot seat the show at the
harder season even hotter questions
today we got kat hello
it's a new type of segment that we got
here um we started off kind of cold kind
of basic just to get to know you and
then we turn up the heat because you are
sitting on the game of thrones uh chair
in the hot seat yep we can't legally say
that yeah
but
but
yeah she looks so small compared to you
right now just
like you mentioned all the way back i
looked i looked like this it's a very
fitting chair for you though yeah it's
perfect
okay so uh first question on a hot seat
we would like to just get getting to
know you a little bit yeah um what's
something that a lot of people don't
really know about you
um something a lot of people don't
really know about me uh i would say
that i am a very like
shy person i like to keep to myself i
don't really like to talk to people
unless i'm smoking too i think it's a
trouble you don't you don't seem shy at
all oh i fake it i fake it you just put
it on like a suit put it on put it on
the suit
when you take it off like when you're
home and you're with your dude is that
when you're the most comfortable because
yes absolutely i think uh he's kind of
released something in me because he
loves being verbally abused as his lover
previous relationship like i would kind
of walk on eggshells so i couldn't
really speak my mind be out of fear of
like hurting his feelings so i'd filter
everything that i said my boyfriend now
wants me to like cuss him the [ __ ] out
at any point in time of year what are
some of his favorite abusive uh words
that you use is it a sexual thing you
make it sound very sexual no it's more
so like that's how he knows how to
accept like love sounds like endearment
yes he feels like if i don't say
anything and i hold in my feelings that
i don't love him so if i'm verbally
abusing him he knows like oh she's still
in it because like no one would cuss at
me like this if they didn't care about
me
like tough love right stupid little
[ __ ] i love her so much i'll tell him
to shut the [ __ ] up all the time um i
will call him a dumb [ __ ] oh cool call
him little [ __ ] boy
what do you what does he do when you
call him a [ __ ] boy nothing he just
like laughs and he thinks that's the
cutest thing because i'm also like like
what am i gonna do yeah i'm picturing
him wearing a diaper for some reason and
putting a pacifier in his mouth after
you call him he shows up like this
wow okay
i got a question so like
for people who don't know who you are
right yeah there might be some new
viewers yeah what would you say like
well how would you like summarize what
you do who you are and all that stuff
yeah well i work on a podcast called the
fighter and the kid i worked behind the
scenes for a while and a lot of people
didn't see my face for the first few
months because i was supposed to be off
camera just like working social media
and when they heard my voice i have a
deeper voice than what people would
expect when they oh yeah fashion girl
yeah so just hearing my voice and not
seeing what i look like everyone assumed
that i was like this chubby like butch
asian girl because they also knew that i
was like power lifting at the time so
they they had this very specific idea of
what i look like and then i was put on
camera as i continue to work and
everyone started immediately went like
sim mode oh you're like holy [ __ ] like
we thought you were gonna look like a
[ __ ]
cause you don't sound like an anime
character
i think they they thought i was going to
look more like a like a shrek not at the
con
track yeah yeah yeah which is fine he
should shrek i [ __ ] with shrek i think
he's dope oh yeah sure nobody wants a
[ __ ] shrek but yeah
and then i got like super sexualized but
like specifically my feet because i
guess but internet people are into feet
how do they know about your feet when
all of the show is up from here um i
talked about some weird dm's i used to
get and most of them for some reason
were just people asking to see my feet
and so i talked about it became a joke
where everyone wanted to see my feet i
hid my feet for a really long time like
two years would wear air force ones to
the beach and [ __ ] wow wow did you blur
out your feet huh and then eventually i
started pimping out my feet during the
pandemic to make some extra money you
really
you you didn't you did a great debut on
like your feet like you kept it the
build-up hidden
you know it was like and then bam you
[ __ ] charged you did it right
you didn't [ __ ] like it was like
halle berry and her boobs and swordfish
thank you yeah
that's genius or some [ __ ] right yeah no
it's crazy good for her
and then you became you became a foot
model yeah my whole thing is i tell
people i'm the hottest foot model on the
internet
is there is there like a category like
on only fans you could be like oh tits
ass whatever and then it's like you have
like menus when you subscribe to their
page they'll send you a message right
off the bat like hey if you want to see
like x y and z this is how much it's
gonna cost for me i just kind of wait
until the dms come my way and then i'll
respond
across the board can we like see some
like ankle right now some angles yeah
give us a little teaser
here's the thing
screw your business over here i'm so
protective of my feet that i wear high
socks no matter wow
are you the number one foot girl on only
fans i would like to say yes no i want
to say yes but there's no you don't
study the competition and what the [ __ ]
they do you a like ranking you know
where you rank up in the grand scheme of
how many other accounts there are
because they have a like oh you're in
the top like 10 of people who are making
money on only fans you're the top five
percent they they'll give you that
breakdown and based off of that you can
kind of tell what other people are
making if you know they're ranking
what's what's action in the foot model
world where you see it like i can't
believe people fall for this [ __ ]
yes dude i don't question i don't know
too many other girls who do specifically
uh feet modeling but i want to say like
a good price from what i've seen is like
if you want to put it on a wall where
like a paywall you start at like five to
like seven dollars if it's just strictly
feet and then you make your money in
pay-per-views because people will do a
lot of requests like oh i want you to
step in cake or like i want you to walk
barefoot for a day and then take photos
of your uh the soles of your feet people
are sick up there man is there so
specific is there like a face tuned for
foot where like people cheat and make
their feet look better i think you can
but what i've noticed is the
things that make the most money are kind
of like the niche grimier [ __ ] so you
want like
4k
that's pretty cool as realistic as
possible they want to see every detail
they want girl next door feet
not like hollywood feet yeah they don't
want their like bow tie hollywood feet
what's the most specific request you've
gotten for your feet um a lot of people
have asked for this thing called foot
worshiping which i don't do because it's
basically where you suck on your own
toes how do you do that so i guess you
just have to be flexible enough to like
get your toe to your mouth can you
achieve that range of motion i don't
know i don't know if i can yeah can you
be honest i've seen babies do it yeah
but ugh bro
can you guys do it no [ __ ] no
i think if i have assistance i can't
like bro you could do anything can
worship his foot you don't need another
stream of income don't get good at that
dude this is a cat's hot seat okay no
man why are you trying to [ __ ]
overshadow her [ __ ]
[Laughter]
don't make me insecure about
participating
is the best comeback that's the worst
comeback i've ever heard that was as bad
as i can turn the quarters on the arcade
machine guys don't mess with me
like that was a comeback
cat yeah
are you [ __ ] with us though like are
you doing what you did on the fighter on
the kid where you're saying like i'm not
gonna do
foot worship and then secretly in the
background like oh
two months [ __ ]
yes
okay yes and no cause i had a game plan
going into it i don't do feet worshiping
that's just not my thing
um but i had a plan going into it that
i'm gonna start out saying that i'm only
doing feet because i knew what i was
comfortable with from the beginning if i
just take photos like all these girls do
on instagram but put it behind a paywall
i just need to be able to market it
properly where i knew a bunch of people
had this idea like oh maybe we can
convince her to do more once she starts
seeing like the money come in and i
already knew that was going to be the
game plan so i started saying like oh
i'm only doing feet guys only feet and
then slowly like okay maybe i'll take a
few selfies and it progressed to me
getting to the point that i was
comfortable with which is just like
lingerie stuff and so i slowly started
doing that and people got excited
thinking oh we're like maybe we can push
her to do more right some like a part of
that following do have this kink of like
trying to exploit a vulnerable girl so
then i take advantage of that's [ __ ]
so good because you know your audience
and then you you kind of take them
through the journey that they want
that's like entertaining
that's really what it is you're like
when porn then right basically yeah
basically especially because my uh
boyfriend used to do porn so they see
the likelihood of like oh we could watch
them [ __ ] yeah yeah that's what i think
people are ultimately waiting for but
there's like a narrative they're paying
to follow absolutely because i would say
not
every single person who follows me or
follows my only fans are people who like
me it's people who also want to slowly
watch like the story of like this like
girl who used to work behind the scenes
like slowly crumble into this hollywood
and feel responsible yeah i feel like oh
i'm part of this like downfall today's
video is brought to you by tushy
oh man you know what's cool is they sent
me a bidet
hello tushy bidet three years ago now
it's been some time the same one by the
way still hasn't broken i'm pretty
impressed because it's such a simple
design yeah um when you think of bidet
right especially if you like been to
japan and and you know a lot of asian
families do use one yeah but they're
like super duper high tech you have to
plug it in the wall all this stuff and
it's cool and all but then like i don't
have any electrical sockets near my
toilet or anything so this was a perfect
design for me because you use the
pressure from the toilet the water
pressure from there it just goes
straight up and you don't have to use
anything else but that and the knob just
goes one way the different power
pressure for your booty holes and then
it goes another way where it could clean
out the actual tube that sprays water
from nice so it's a real clean design
real quick and easy to install and it's
lasted me three years it's a long time
and it's pretty freaking awesome yeah it
makes it really easy and you get the
cleanest butt ever way better than
toilet paper way better than wet wipes
like it's literally a mini shower for
your butt you just spray you pat dry and
what's cool about it is i've had the
super complicated ones before too not a
fan because sometimes you got a higher
electrician you got to hire a plumber so
it makes it a crazy job this thing just
connects straight to your toilet and you
can cut down your toilet paper used by
80 which is insane that's what i love
because i'm super duper cheap yeah and
the thing is
after you spray your booty hoe and it
has a nice shower
you never use that much paper yeah it's
just dab dab dab and you're just like
ready to go yeah so for this holiday
season if you're like oh what should i
get that's different that i've never
given before give it to your brother
your sister you know your brother's got
a stinky butt yeah yeah i knew everybody
in the whole world got stinky butts and
everyone could use a nice clean bum bum
so go to hellotushy.com off the record
to get 10 percent off and you can get
yourself one you can buy as many as you
want pedal tissue.com slash off the
record to get 10 off to get a tushy
bidet nice and clean for your butt and
your whole family this holiday season so
it's different from like those instagram
girls that are like uh
thirst trapping yeah and you know like
every single time they're like oh if you
want to follow me follow my friend and
then you gotta click a friend and you oh
if you want to follow me you gotta
follow my friend and i keep clicking the
click and before you know it i have 10
[ __ ]
only fans about 10 000 people they all
collaborate and that's what my second
question is run by one guy
how do you
make me hug i think so but how do you
collaborate with other
like
feet fluencers i think it's different
from person to person because some girls
have agencies that they will work with
and agents what an agency would do is
basically uh you can
depending on your agency some of them
will just help you set up photo shoots
and they're like okay if you pay us this
much every single month we'll set up the
photo shoot so you don't have to worry
about getting good quality content and
then some girls like almost like a 360
deal where they're like oh i don't want
to respond to dm so will you also do
that for me and so like people will hire
agencies to do their entire account
pretending like it's them is that
happening
oh that's how a lot of girls will do
their [ __ ] like for me i will respond to
dms but then if i have like a new flood
of people coming in from something like
let's say i do this show and then i get
like a bump in subscribers
and i can't go through all the dms if
some people are just asking a quick
question of like oh how much for this
pay-per-view can you send it to me i
have someone go through and then send
them the pay-per-views but interactions
conversations that's still me hey i'm
looking uh i heard somebody say you you
did a step in an orbeez video i'm not
finding it am i spelling it wrong yeah
yeah that's basically what it is it's
fantastic wow
it really depends on what you're looking
for we've reached the 11 minute and 47
second point of the show which is part
of the show we like to take it down and
get real raw and emotional yeah um so my
first question to you is as a somebody
who describes himself as more of like a
quiet person or even like as a person
who um you're putting certain
vulnerabilities obviously targeted
vulnerabilities to exploit a certain
fantasy in people's minds yeah do you
get a certain power out of not revealing
your real vulnerabilities to the
internet uh
not like uh power i think i became very
like i got exhausted of trying to
explain myself to people after a while
because when you first start on the
internet uh at the at the very least for
me i felt like if i explained myself
maybe this person just like
misunderstood what i was saying or where
i'm coming from if i take the time to
have a conversation with them maybe
they'll get it and very quickly i
realize some people are just committed
to not liking you and wanting to
misunderstand you like oh [ __ ] it oh
yeah like blasting people out
like if somebody leaves a shitty comment
and i read it i usually don't read my
comments or my dms anymore but any every
now and then if i do and someone says
something shitty i'll like tag their
fiance or like oh yeah
that's good [ __ ] that's nice that's
really nice that's really good that's
sick as [ __ ] guys
did you know you raised your kid like
this yeah exactly i was like hey i don't
know why your boyfriend's like sending
me [ __ ] online when he has a beautiful
woman like you like i never [ __ ] on the
girlfriend or anything it's just like
hey come get your boyfriend
it's a shame you guys have a daughter i
hope your daughter doesn't have to do it
that's how it should be handled though
it's well deserved you guys have a
blessed day
that's funny they use their real
accounts because most [ __ ] faces they
have a burner account and then they they
talk [ __ ] on that because they're too
cowardly to show their face some people
do burner accounts but i i do
take the time for people who are so
cocky that they want to do it from their
actual account yeah set them on fire
play ball look play ball
what's something that does get to you be
like [ __ ] a every time i agree
completely
uh every time i would say any time
somebody says something about like
uh
like being like too much because i think
i have childhood traumas of like family
members saying that so like if someone
says that i'm like being too much doing
too much like a like something's wrong
with my personality then i take that to
heart because then in my head it takes
me back to when i was a kid yes and
that's those are the things that usually
used to bother me what do you mean like
too much um a lot of people like i
remember when
i started being on camera a lot of it
was my boss had heard that people liked
the sound of me laughing at a joke
and so they would put a mic so they
could hear me laugh and i laugh at
basically everything like asmr stuff
like it's like it feels good i think
they liked hearing a girl giggling in an
all-guy type of cast because it kind of
broke up the monotony of like these
dudes making raunchy jokes and the more
i was on camera the more than the
attention was on me and people then like
found a new target to find to find
something wrong with it yeah right
that's what always happens
always happened without fail and i
learned to deal with it better as i
continue to do the job but it's
definitely something i didn't understand
was going to be like a huge part of
working on social media yeah
yeah that happens here all the time too
fans are pretty nice even when they're
mean they're [ __ ] nice yeah i felt
like your fans were the best yeah very
different from fire than the kid that's
well part of the kids [ __ ] insane
they're a bunch of piranhas yeah
damn i i just felt that i just felt that
really hard actually they're [ __ ]
like aggressive but in a way where like
i get it i just wish that they would be
able to take it the way they dish it
yeah because like that [ __ ]
like if you're on like a comedy podcast
like
tr like audience
and you're trying to like give someone
[ __ ] you should be able to take the [ __ ]
back
after i attack someone's like girlfriend
or boyfriend they're like you're trying
to ruin a relationship it's like well he
[ __ ] left the comment
it's not my fault i'm putting a
flashlight on the comment because this
[ __ ] are we talking about i know and
like if his girlfriend isn't mad at it
she isn't mad at her if she is she is
like who the [ __ ] cares wow not that
dude they're trying to release you're
gonna break them up in the relationship
they have a child together like okay
you can tell that none of these [ __ ]
actually have a relationship
i kind of want to make a burner account
now
oh everyone i know has a burner account
oh yeah i have three history and nobody
wants to [ __ ] admit it
i think it's because like i work in the
comedy scene i say most people don't
like the big comedians don't have burner
accounts but the people who work for
them usually have burner accounts
it's either to like look through
comments on accounts to see like oh like
why don't these people like me
engagement-wise like what's happening
like how do we help yeah for like work
purposes or they'll go through reddit to
see what people are saying and then try
to adjust the show to that but they
don't want
like this employee going on someone's
like instagram story and seeing them
like [ __ ] on the show
like everyone has a burner account
nobody oh i have a burner account i
[ __ ] tell my wife she's a ugly [ __ ]
every day
[Laughter]
that way i don't have to say it to her
face
and she appreciates that
you
you're stefan g that's why i thought
that was steve graham's [ __ ] jesus
i thought it was graham stefan you
[ __ ]
you're right anime
brian anime yeah
you [ __ ] [ __ ] man so when you go
home after this yeah and you take off
the suit that is cat that the cat that
we're seeing right now yeah how much of
it of this is different than how much of
you is you uh i think i'm much more like
aloof
i feel like a sloth
okay like it's just kind of like i'm
like a vegetable i'm just kind of like
there i'll interact every now and then
like very slow moving you're slower than
now yes
[Music]
what's that yeah that's like double slow
motion the only time she had one of
these too it's like come on you know
the only time i amp it up is if like my
boyfriend needs a little extra love and
i custom the [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
you ever do any drugs uh no i wish which
ones uh i wish i smoked more wheat i was
always afraid of drugs graham is not a
drug it's a plant oh yes uh i wish i
tried e i wish i did shrooms i wish i
tried coke but why wish why not do i
think i'm scared of it like i still have
oh dude fear of something's gonna go
wrong because i know mentally yeah don't
do it if you're scared you don't want to
[ __ ] anything up with like the dopamine
and the serotonin so that's what i'm
afraid of i'm not scared i'm just scared
about doing it too much yeah
i like things too [ __ ] much that's
fear still it's okay yeah no but like
not like scared of the experience yeah
you're not scared man you're brave no
i'm scared of what was your favorite
drug if you could do it all the time and
have no negative reproduction no
negative yeah
and you had unlimited serotonin yeah not
everything's still normal
what the [ __ ]
nitrous oxide holy [ __ ] like that
the balloons
that's the thing you do all the time
every day bro oh what's it like yeah
it's like you are a hot air balloon
what the [ __ ]
so it's like cosplay
different vehicles so you're dangerous
around power lines
your whole body is kind of numb floaty
and then you're you kind of got like
vertical but not really you're not dizzy
so you're just kind of like [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] how long does it last when
you take a hit well i don't know because
you keep you have a huge balloon and you
keep breathing that [ __ ]
and you just hold your breath
yeah oh so you just go back and forth
man i did i did everything except for
heroin and shrooms yeah so
and [ __ ] so i ended up doing acid
instead she ended up getting turned into
a hot air balloon instead
yeah scary
my friend said that he became a sponge
in the shower and when
um
he was like taking a shower he's like oh
[ __ ] dude
i can't take turn this off because if i
turn off the water this is my life
supply and i need to stay soaked up and
then he's like if i turn this off and i
squeeze all the water out of my system i
die and i was like i ain't [ __ ] doing
shrooms bro he's legitimately recreating
a scene from the spongebob movie yeah
that is from spongebob yeah oh yeah
maybe spongebob maybe
he's just describing a movie he ate
mushrooms and watched spongebob and he
was like i'm the sponge
but it ain't about me what about you you
want to do drugs yeah you want to do
some dress i do but i'm i'm scared i'm
very afraid of it and my boyfriend says
that's a big note it is because you
gotta it's a slippery slope you gotta
wanna do it like
you gotta [ __ ] thirst for every time
you think about it you gotta yearn for
it
i can't wait it's [ __ ] salivating
right now dude i think i know that meme
i know the meme you're doing
the black guy by the tree you know
that's a good man
i think my boyfriend's worried because
he's like well if you get into drugs now
you're i feel like you're gonna go have
a moment when you're on a bender and
you're making money now like you you're
not like broken he's trying drugs he's
like you're gonna lose everything bad
position wow
you know what i'm trying to do that you
know what my new drug is
my new drug i think you're gonna like
this hold your breath
dude you get into some [ __ ] up
no no no no no no no on that come on
please breathe please please it's called
the wind half breathing method
windhuff you take three wim hof
deep breaths it's a guy and then you
hold your breath like a [ __ ]
right my time right now the most i could
do is three minutes and 30 seconds three
yeah and then
you release
you take one inhale and then you hold
for 15 seconds and then you just release
and you just [ __ ] breathe and it's
just [ __ ] it's nice
like you're super light-headed is that
it it's light-headed it's just it
actually is really healthy for you it's
actually a technique by a guy named uh i
think eric wim hof uh he like [ __ ] is
like naked in the cold and hikes up
mountains and [ __ ] like that but uh when
you breathe with that type of exercise
you're re-oxygenating your blood cells
and keeping the flow in a certain way
that like reinvigorates your body so
it's actually
that's easy i think he's called
kundalini breathing is what he learned
it's
i feel like i just watched a segment on
joe rogan yeah
and that cures covenant i think i just
watched pulling focus with anthony lee
what the [ __ ]
he can't say anything
you